hi I'm Erik Bosse and the spider-man far
from home truly brought up a lot of
questions chief among them Pete dead I
saw it he's dryer lint now as I
explained in my breakdown the trailer
this footage is filled with cryptic
clues about the timeline of spider-man
far from home when does it take place
how will it connect to have interest in
game and Avengers infinity war why in
this trailers no one talking about
thanasis snap was it reversed did Marvel
to spoil its own movie I'm gonna explain
three explanations for spider-man's
apparent resurrection after his very
visible death at the end of infinity war
it's more than warning in case any of
these are too accurate and I ruin your
life okay how is Peter Parker alive
again explanation one spider-man far
from home is a prequel for many of you
the go-to theory was that far from home
could actually be set before the events
of infinity war and yeah everyone here
seems pre Thanos happy Peter is still
using a stark tech suit given to him in
Civil War the one he had before the
events of infinity war and the fact that
no one seems to be talking about the
notion of a snap or half the world
dusting kind of weird but really we
don't know what year this movie takes
place in a close-up of Peters passport
in the trailer mysteriously removed the
years from the issue date expiration
date and birth date it's like the
editors intentionally did not want us to
be able to determine from this trailer
alone when this all happened
maybe the play it's safe to protect
Peter from getting his identity stolen
but I mentioned this explanation first
because I want to get out of the way
spider-man far from home it's not a
prequel the head of Marvel Studios Kevin
Feige a man with very hands on control
of all of these stories confirmed it is
set after endgame so today me Pascal a
head of Sony the studio co producing
this film the school bus that Peter was
riding an infinity war was not a school
bus taking him home from the airport
from a euro trip Peter actually says he
was on his way to a field trip at moma
also spider-man far from home will be
the first movie of Marvel phase 4 it's a
new chapter why would it be said in some
weird retcon timeline between chapters
within phase 3 really the fact that
Peter Parker is alive again and the
world seems unaffected by the snap is
probably the result of some timeline
trickery that The Avengers will use in
endgame which brings me to the second
explanation
spider-man far from home takes place in
an alternate timeline within the Marvel
multiverse huh multiverse is a theory
that our universe is actually one of int
two parallel realities you may have seen
this in the recent animated film
spider-man into the spider verse which
showed how spider-man may die in one
universe but he could live on in many
different forms and other universes so
maybe this Peter and his friends
belonged to a different reality far from
the whole reality we know but how could
the Avengers split into another reality
well the physics are complicated but and
ant-man the wasp Bill Foster Marvell
Morpheus reference quantum particles
phase shifting into multiple parallel
realities perhaps and man's time stuck
in the quantum realm will cause him to
phase shift it to a parallel reality and
maybe that is why cap and Natasha are so
confused to see him in the front gate in
this end game trailer like maybe this
Scott Lang comes from our home reality
and he's now in a reality in which she
had dusted so that's why they're shocked
to see him
if endgame introduces the multiverse
into the live-action MCU really the
possibilities will be endless but a
third explanation has already been
introduced so let's try that one out
The Avengers will use time travel to
reset the timeline and prevent Thanos to
snap so what are the ways they could do
this well there are three established
means of time travel in the insu's so
far let's run through them one the time
stone which can rewind the direction of
time by limited amounts can also create
time loops so that time keeps replaying
from one anchor point it also allows one
to look forward in time at all possible
timelines another way there apparently
time vortexes in the quantum realm like
Scott Lang might have gone through one
of these time vortexes judging from that
archive Easter egg an endgame trailer
check out one of my videos on that
subject and a third means of time travel
Sam Jackson just revealed that Captain
Marvel has the ability to time travel
okay like with the multiverse there are
a lot of different permutations of this
working like maybe dr. strange could
have hidden the time stone itself in
time like in the future or in the past
giving future or past versions of the
Avengers a chance to use it in crazy
ways or Scott Lang or Carol Danvers
could drag other Avengers with them
through their means of time-travel I
have a theory on this that kind of ties
it all together and I'll get to that in
a second but first thank you to privacy
comm for sponsoring this video
privacy comm is a free service that
allows you to create burner credit card
numbers to pay for transactions online
so you don't have to use your real
credit card or debit card number to pay
for every purchase it's just so easy for
people to steal your credit card info
like I always wants burned by one of
those devices that they call skimmers
you know one of those things that people
can just pop onto card swipers at ATMs
or gas pumps anywhere any part of town
and then sometime later I saw a bunch of
charges at an adult video store in
Florida and I hadn't been to the
Gainesville Ex Mart in years and I
wasn't blowing money there like it was
Vegas
we should never worry about someone
stealing your credit card again privacy
calm takes care of that check it out
I've set up an account with privacy calm
and I've linked my bank account and I'm
creating a dummy credit card to pay for
a YouTube red subscription I'm gonna set
the limit of this card for $1 so I can
just try out YouTube red for free for a
month and say later on I forget to
cancel the subscription rather than
YouTube trying to charge me the full
amount for another month privacy will
block them because this burner cards one
dollar limit was maxed out it's so easy
and again it is free and we're gonna
make this feel even better for you guys
first time customers who sign up with
privacy calm / new rock stars will get a
$5 credit on their first purchase with
privacy calm and as an added bonus we
are gonna team up with privacy calm to
completely pay off the first purchases
for five random people so just break
this down that's a $5 credit that we're
giving first-time sign ups plus the
chance to have your first purchase
through privacy fully covered so you
gotta try this out we gotta use our link
go to privacy calm / new rock stars
that's PR IVAC y comm slash any WRO c KS
t ARS to hit a $5 credit on your first
purchase now okay back to my grand
theory of how the Avengers could use
time travel to reset this timeline let's
just point out how weird it would be to
have different sources of time-travel in
a movie right like I wonder if the
source of Captain Marvel's time-travel
capabilities could be the same as
ant-man
time vortexes in the quantum realm
perhaps when Captain Marvel goes binary
she's actually absorbing quantum energy
down from this subatomic realm that
golden rainbow glow she gives off is
kind of similar to the color palette of
the quantum realm
and wasp but what if this version of
time travel that we're seeing in this
movie isn't the traditional kind you
know where a human displaces his or her
whole body to reappear in an earlier or
later time period but instead time
travel of the mind consciousness
displacement where only your mind it
travels back in time to an earlier point
in your own life allowing you to relive
past moments and make different choices
we saw this with Wolverine in the movie
x-men Days of Future past we start with
the character Desmond in the show lost
the character of Billy Pilgrim and Kurt
Vonnegut's novel slaughterhouse-five the
hero in a screenplay I wrote that no one
will buy any that's what captain
Marvel's version of time-travel looks
like that could explain why her upcoming
movie appears to be so focused on the
whole concept of memory perhaps she is
unstuck in time with her consciousness
repeatedly drifting her back to past
moments and this whole movie is about
her struggle to control this as a power
so how could carol danvers use this to
stop Thanos well captain Marvel's pretty
powerful
gingka does blink back to past moments
of her own timeline as early as the 80s
or 90s to try to destroy each Infinity
stone before Thanos gets his hands on
them but despite her immense power that
would be tough logistically many of the
stones soulstone the reality stone the
time stone the power stone they always
were pretty guarded under lock and key
rarely were they ever out in the open
before Thanos got to him so consider
this option barth consider it Tony
Stark's binary augmented retro framing
that memory reconstruction technology if
Carol can find a way to help everyone
use the quantum energy that she uses to
rewind their consciousnesses back to
past moments maybe Tony Stark can
combine that with barf to help them
reconstruct specific past moments that
they came into contact with Infinity
stones think about a Tony and Carol
could help rocket go back to his brief
contact with a Power Stone the first
guardians the galaxy they could help
Thor go back to when he came close to
the reality stone in Thor the dark world
they could help Wong go back to when he
had the time stone in his hands through
the eye of agamotto and one of the
sanctums they could out banner or really
any of the others go back to when the
mine stone was in their possession and
age of Ultron they could help cap or any
of the others again go back to when the
tesseract was within their grasp now the
soul stone would be trickier since it
was on form
here but maybe they could use this
tactic on Thanos to allow this grieving
father to revisit his biggest sacrifice
exchanging his daughter for one of these
stones this way
I think the Avengers could go stone by
stone retrieving or destroying them but
ultimately preventing the mad Titan from
snapping half of them away creating a
new timeline in which Peter Parker and
Nick Fury are alive well and hanging out
in Europe this strategy may or may not
require personal sacrifices by each of
the main Avengers no no the far from
home trailer mentioned Iron Man and Thor
by name and no one seemed that sad to
bring them up it sounds like they're
still alive in this timeline I could
imagine a version this work cap goes
back to the 1940s destroys the tesseract
and decides to stay there you know so he
could finally get that dance of Peggy
Carter that could be why Chris Evans
signaled his conclusion in that tweet
last year this obviously isn't confirmed
theory let me know what you think about
the comments below but here is my
question for you guys do you think
Marvel's spoiled in-game with the
spider-man far from home trailer I hear
you showing Peter Parker alive is kind
of a weird way to show that the stakes
of infinity war aren't what we thought
they were but personally I think the far
from home trailer played things right by
avoiding any timeline explanation look
guys we knew this sequel was coming even
before Peter Parker dusted away and if
you honestly saw all those infinity war
deaths as permanent life must be very
hard for you and what would the
alternative be like another infinity war
prequel like ant-man the wasp was and
Captain Marvel is gonna be or would you
prefer releasing no far from home
trailer until after endgame comes out
what do you expect me to starve comment
down below with your thoughts and follow
new rockstars on twitter at new
rockstars and follow me on twitter and
instagram at a vas and subscribe to new
rockstars for in-depth writedowns
explanations and theories of everything
Marvel related there's been fun but I'm
gonna time travel my mind back to the
first time I got laid tail I guess that
didn't count